what do you do for money now um right
now i'm sucking dick
and whatever it is i got to do to get
whatever money i got to get and i'm
pretty
i'm really good at it so that's why i
mean i don't i don't turn down those
favor for favors i do what i got to do
to get money and that's what i do and
i'm good at it so [ __ ] it
all right janet janet uh where'd you
grow up where are you from originally i
grew up in south central
and tell me about your family you had
both parents growing up i had a mom that
was
um stay-at-home mom but she worked
various little jobs to get by
um my dad was in and out of the house
doing what he could to make ends meet um
i stayed mostly with babysitters um they
had me laying in bed with them
sometimes from time to time they would
have certain females that would come and
um have certain guys or certain hats i
have certain females laying in bed with
me as a baby as a child
i stayed there majority of all the day
all the night eating beans and rice
and that was pretty much it i you know
stayed with them
um they always had me in the bed while
all the other kids played and
in the street and it was just kind of
awkward kind of weird
you know so sexual things going on um i
if i if as a kid i can't really recall
but i'm pretty sure
because we're in the bed you know they
would make me stay in the bed so
um and those females would basically
pretty much
have certain females come over and make
them lay in the bed with me
and i just didn't get it as a child i
didn't know i didn't understand
so
we stayed there majority of me and my
brother my brother
me my other my other sister and brother
stayed there majority of the nights my
mom worked various jobs i was out and
about doing whatever spending whatever
money
i didn't have any clothes growing up i
had holes in my socks going to school
i you know was always a hungry child
always looking for food
i don't know i just never really got
what i wanted as a child growing up for
christmas
um it was just always a deprived
situation with me all the time
so how were your high school years um
high school
i pretty much i worked from the age of
14
up until 25 which was well not 25
around 22 23 my mom passed away um it's
kind of awkward how i found my mom
um one night i was out smoking weed i
started smoking weed and
experimenting with drugs when i was 21.
i came home one night after hanging out
with some friends and
i went upstairs and went to sleep came
back downstairs
and i just kind of felt my way
downstairs trying to get some water some
drink i was so thirsty
um waking up in the middle of the night
and i i felt something on the on the
on the floor and i'm like what is this
what is this and
i i turned the light on and i was just
shocked out of my mind to find that it
was my mom dead on the floor
and there was like no explanation for it
whatsoever
so i was like what the [ __ ] my mom
is dead on the floor and they're like
my dad was in shock my brother was in
shock
i was in shock and i'm the one that
found her and there was no explanation
for her
being on on the floor or dead so
i'm screaming out of my mind
hysterically
um and but i just i felt something
wasn't right i just felt something
wasn't right
um shortly after my mom's birthday was
six seven days after that which was
the 26th of march of 2005.
[Music]
and it was just a horrible day it was a
horrible day
shortly after after the funeral my my
dad
my brother and my sister took off and
they went to vegas
and i was stuck there at the house that
weekend by myself
with nothing just feeling alone feeling
depressed
i wasn't really into smoking cocaine
around that time but i
was experimenting every now and again
with crack
um but um you know i didn't really get
into the meth habit
until um i came out here to la i'm
you know by myself my my dad ended up
getting with some
young young girl 18 years old ended up
getting her pregnant
shortly after it just was an awkward
situation because at first me and her
got along but then me and her didn't get
along
he ended up kicking me out of the house
and putting out a restraining order
against me
when he put a straining order out
against me i ended up moving with a
neighbor
so they ended up kicking me out over a
fight i got
i got into with the neighbor um and i
just kind of made my way on the
greyhound out here to la because i said
if i'm gonna be homeless i might as well
be out here i probably have more
opportunities
as a homeless uh you know person out
here where were you living at the time
i was living in mourinho valley okay
riverside county
uh out there in ie do you have uh
kids of your own i don't have any
children at all so i'm blessed to have
no kids right now
and i'm homeless on the street living in
a tent right now you're on schedule
um on skid row um just kind of
you know are using crystal meth i'm
using crystal meth that's
my that's basically my medication i use
that all day every day and there's
nothing else i want to use but crystal
meth because
of the fact that i need to be able to
stay
on a normal page which is i need to be
able to function if something is to go
down or something just to happen
on the streets i got to be ready for
whatever wherever life takes
me so and there's a lot of physical
abuse with men out here these men are
abusive they beat women up especially
black women
they like to fight black women they like
to [ __ ] black women up real bad
over any and every little thing out here
so pretty much i have to stay
on my p's and q's and i have to be able
to to
defend myself if i'm in a situation
where i'm not able to defend myself
so with that being said i smoke that
every day
and that's what keeps me energetically
up for the day
i'm you know broken down more than
normal
you know and i have to be able to
function on a normal page with everybody
else in society
so what do you do for money now um right
now i'm
sucking dick in whatever it is i got to
do to get whatever money i got to get
and i'm pretty
i'm really good at it so that's why i
mean i don't i don't turn down those
favor for favors i do what i got to do
to get money and that's what i do
and i'm good at it so [ __ ] it do you
have friends on the street
um i have guy friends that i talk to
that i can trust in that i pretty much
you know befriend in case you know
situations happen where i have to have
another guy step in and they have to
basically defend me when
in whatever situation i didn't had dudes
on the street that i was cool with that
and beat the [ __ ] out of me over
right there in front of the apple store
right there on san pedro
um i didn't had all types of [ __ ] happen
to me that just
you know ain't been cool i ain't been
cool at all and
and it's embarrassing you know when you
get beat up i do when a dude hits you
like you're a [ __ ] male or you know
me like they're taking you on like
they're a man
it's just really embarrassing for the
for you know
the public to sit there and watch that
and no one step in and no one
no one help out and you know i didn't
have too many things happen to where i
just
i i stand i try to stay to myself as
much as i possibly can um sometimes days
are slow where i don't have no money and
i have to
you know i have to you know kick it with
certain guys just kicking with certain
people and they'll bring me
you know they'll bring me whatever
crystal meth i need to smoke for the day
to keep me energized for the day or
whatever
but what's the hardest part of your life
um the hardest part of my life
is pretty much just
not being able to have money in my
pocket pretty much
you know it just feels like everything's
falling down when i don't have any money
i feel like i have to basically do
whatever
to get a meal or whatever i don't i mean
your back's against the wall every day
yeah pretty much because
it's like i rather have something in my
pocket pretty much for the day so i can
i feel
like i have leverage leverage in my life
to be able to make more
you know decisions for myself i'm more
open to do what i want and have what i
want and not have to sit there and
settle
so i mean me having money in my pocket
means a lot
you know being in this situation but
when i don't have it things are just
oh i have to basically take things for
you know what it is and how they come
you know and i don't like having to live
like that are you worried about diseases
at all
um pretty much diseases is something
that
i mean if you nurture a disease it will
eventually grow and die out you know you
have to be able to know
you know go to school and have you know
smarts
to be able to know how to balance your
your chemical balance and what
you can tolerate in your body and what
you can't tolerate
how i can get rid of this disease how i
can do this what can i do to nurture
this and if i take good care of myself
and i'm not
um putting myself in the same
predicament where i'm active with the
same guys that are giving me certain
things then i'm not going to get this
disease anymore
if i'm if i'm taking the right
medication that they're giving me at
these clinics then
it'll it shall die out it shall pass you
know what i'm saying so
um that's not really something i really
worry about a whole lot because i do use
protection
and um i'm not really sexually active i
suck a lot of dicks so i like sucking
dick and i'm good at it so i pretty much
that's what i pretty much do and i mean
you know i make good money doing it you
know so what does crystal meth do for
you now crystal meth um kind of
just gives me gets me motivated
sometimes it gets me in the mood so
that's
another thing that it does for me not
just only does it keep me up and on my
toes every day
and energized but it also gets me in a
more satisfying relaxed
mood to where i can kind of chill i can
kick back i can be myself
i can feel more i can feel more relaxed
in situations and not
but but sometimes when i smoke too much
of it i get real paranoid so i get
paranoid to where i'm always looking
over my shoulder
and that's not cool but i mean that's
when i smoke too much of it so i know
how to balance
balance it out by smoking maybe a little
bit of weed with it so
what's been the worst part of your life
the worst part of my life
the rough roughest point of your life
the roughest point
i i would say um
just balancing my relationships and
trying to basically
just historically throughout your life
when you were younger or not um
the just not having
some stability stability meaning not
having
truths in certain situations with with
any and everybody i do lot a lot a lot
on the streets i do a lot of humiliation
i deal
with a lot of just embarrassing
situations and
um just a lot of negative talk and
knowing how to get over that negative
talk
is one of the biggest problems that i
have because
in my past it's always been something
that made me
fall in situations on a real serious
note i had to
basically teach myself some sort of
guidance and patience
you know i don't have a whole lot of
mentors or people
to kind of guide me women figures to
kind of guide me in the right direction
you know to give me that good advice and
say hey this is what you need to be
doing versus this
you know i don't really have a whole lot
of that in my life
so that's basically one of the biggest
problems i've always had to
basically self-teach myself how to be
more of an adult i had to learn how to
be an adult at a young age
now i'm at an age where i'm trying to
kick back
i'm trying to relax i've i have i've had
jobs since i was 14. i graduated high
school on time
um and and held a full-time job at the
same time
so that right there is really hard all
in itself
i need to learn how to teach myself how
to relax and not just be
out there and you know doing what
everyone wants me to do
sometimes that is a big problem you know
for for me
is trying to just stay committed to
myself and learning patience
and not giving into what all these guys
want all the time because
these guys that come and they want this
and they want that for this and this and
that
they want always sexual sexual sexual
and
it's never a never situation where
they're trying to please me in the
situation they just want to get pleased
all the time
all the time and it's nothing you can
really do about it majority of the time
because it's like you're
basically getting what they want or what
they have
you're getting you're gaining what they
have you want what they have
which is substance i want i want to
smoke i want to smoke crystal meth
that's what i want if i don't have no
money then i have to come to you to get
it
well then they want their sexual favor
for this hey
sometimes you got to do it or you got to
give in even though it might not be what
you want
other than that you have to go get a job
if you don't have the money to go pay
for it you know what i'm saying which is
majority of the time i always have money
for myself to be able to pay for my own
so i don't really have to really worry
about that but there are times
where um i give in because hey it seems
like a good
you know circumstance to say hey you'll
let me into your apartment i
i can go chill i don't have to worry
about no cops and feeling paranoid
i can come in smoke some some crystal
and
just kick back and not have to be
looking over my shoulder so
can you can you envision a life where
you're off the street living clean
to have a job um um
me going back to work is something that
probably i've been thinking about lately
i've been thinking about getting a job
and going back to work
i want a job that's going to pay me tips
i want something that i'm going to earn
a good amount of money
back when when i was working minimum
wage was about eight something an hour
almost nine
so now that i'm not working it's about
15 something dollars if if not more
i'm sure it's about 15 an hour so i mean
that's pretty
that's a pretty big jump from what it
used to be so
i mean for the most part i mean i can do
that and save money and
and work and you know have something in
my pocket but then when you work
here comes bills here comes other
obligations and other
bills and unnecessarities that i don't
need right now
right now i'm not saying that oh the
life for me
is me being in the streets and it's
living in a tent like i am now
um that's not the life that i want to
live for myself of course not but
right now i don't have any bills i can
save money i can save all the money
work work a job save all the money that
i accumulate
whether it's selling dope or whatever it
is that i got to do to save money so
then i'll have money in my pocket
because if i have an apartment i got to
pay light rent
cable everything else that comes with
with having an apartment you know i'm
saying so
and i won't be able to get gr i won't be
able to get um
i will be able to get um probably food
stamps
maybe if i'm working part-time and i
have a job but
who's who's to know who's to say you
know i'm saying so
do you think that's what attracts a lot
of people to this life down here is just
the lack of responsibility
um you mean me having a job
no just people in general that are
living on the street people people that
are living on the street people that
live on the street have a different
mind state their mind state is basically
saving money
processing all types of things that the
public
once i get into a public community and
and i'm working in a working world
i will not have um the stipulations
that i would have if i was if i was out
here if i was out here
i'm gaining some sort of mental insight
for myself which means that i am growing
i'm changing mentally
um i am developing a a way in a pattern
of life for myself that will get me to a
higher goal for myself that i can reach
if i go out there and i go get a job i'm
not really thinking about my
future a whole lot i'm thinking about
what's going to help me make ends meet
so it'll be job for job and job for job
which can just end up me just working
until an old age
and not really having those goals that i
want i have a
opportunity right now in my life to be
able to think about what goals i want
to get to what job do i actually want to
go get
where do i want to actually go back to
to school do i want to graduate college
do i want to
further my education do i want to take
it to another extent do i want to take
up
something as far as artistry is
concerned i want to be
artists do i want to be a music artist
do i want to be a
painter do i want to be a carpenter what
what is it that i want to actually do
so i have time off from actually
being out there and in an apartment
where i have to basically
i'm not able to think about that i'm
working every day eight hours a day
i don't have a whole lot of time to
really take time to myself to think
about what i want
that's what i'm doing when i go and i
get a job right now versus me just being
out here and on the streets
and actually sitting and and thinking
about what
my next move is going to be so it's
that's
it's like a whole totally different side
of life
that people don't really look at because
they've always been taught just to
you know go to school after high school
or get a job or
whatever their parents wanted them to do
versus what they really want to do
you know how old are you i'm 37 so i'm
pretty old now
but i could still do anything you want i
feel i feel like i'm i'm old like um
if you count every calendar year i guess
you could say i'm 37.
in calendar years but
i don't i mean i have a older mentality
i'm very mature for my age i grew up at
a young age like i said
um i had a lot of things happen to me um
while i've been on the streets since my
mom has passed
um but it's given me time to really
think about
what direction i want to take my life
thank you so much for talking with me
and good luck with whatever you choose
to do thank you very much
you